season four the political docu-series
the circus resumed Sunday on Showtime
ahead of the 2020 primary season
national polls show the race for the
Democratic nomination narrowing between
former Vice President Joe Biden senator
Elizabeth Warren and senator Bernie
Sanders the circus went to a rally for
Warren in New York City so what brings
you to the rally we need to address how
serious things are do you feel like
you're well on your way to becoming the
Democratic nominee you know I'm out
there fighting for it every single day
and really making this democracy work
for every message for supporters of
Bernie Sanders or Vice President Biden
at this moment I have a message for
everybody
2020 is our chance not just to say not
Trump but 2020 is our chance to build
the country of our best dreams and to
make this democracy work for the people
CBS News special correspondent and
co-host of the circus Alex Wagner is in
Cedar Rapids Iowa where many cannons
will be today Alex good morning to you I
can't believe we're talking about crowd
size 20,000 estimated in New York's in
New York for that worin rally what does
that say about her momentum she's got it
Tony that was a big event for Warren not
just in size but in terms of meaning
you saw her framed under Washington
Square Park arch with her campaign sighs
sounds flanking her that was a bid to
show America to show undecided Democrats
that Elizabeth Warren can be a States
woman that she can be the kind of person
that can leave the country in that same
rally she proposed the most sweeping set
of anti-corruption measures in her
campaign words since Watergate that is
something that Democrats broadly see as
a great strategy to defeat Donald Trump
come 2020 Elizabeth Warren wants to
plant her flag in this anti-corruption
strategy it's something all the
Democrats want to use against Trump but
she wants to own
that rally that happened on money Monday
was meaningful for a number of factors
and if you look at the polling around
Warren you see momentum there that rally
only helped with that she's still
running very close with Bernie Sanders
Alex everybody agrees at some point
they're gonna have to go after each
other when is that point gonna be do you
think listen if you talk to Warren
supporters it's really interesting
there's a they like Warren they don't
want to alienate Bernie Sanders
supporters in their support for Warren
they don't want to even alienate Biden
supporters there is a sense inside the
Democratic voting caucus that look we
have favorites but we will get behind
whoever the winner is and within the
Warren campaign in the Sanders campaign
you hear that echoed publicly at the end
of the day though Anthony as you point
out there can only be one nominee I
think this week you heard frustration
from the Sanders campaign Elizabeth
Warren got a coveted endorsement from
the Working Families Party that polling
shows are having momentum there is a
sense that this thing is really
narrowing and it could be a two-way race
rather than a three-way race and you're
hearing frustration from the Sanders
campaign on Twitter and actually at the
actual events Warren meanwhile I think
understands that her path to victory
involves bringing those Sanders voters
into the fold so she has more of a
magnanimous
I think message more more broadly and
even quietly there is a sense that they
cannot win over Sanders supporters by
alienating them but no matter where you
go I cannot underscore enough the sense
of trepidation here among Democratic
voters there is real fear that they've
got a they've got a rally behind their
nominee to defeat Donald Trump because
that is the existential threat facing
the party yeah one thing seems clear
that Democratic voters do not want more
Donald Trump so they may rally around
that if nothing else Alex thank you very
much